I feel like sneaking a balloon of drugs
inside of your orifices of any capacity
is just dangerous because what if the
bus open like do you ever know somebody
no but not even that you're going in
there with your sneakers though like I
mean I'm not even talking about you I
just mean like you always hear like like
chicks will go visit dudes and like
sneak [ __ ] inside of them like you know
I'm like I wonder if that ever goes left
like if the balloon pops open inside of
a chick and then she [ __ ] overdoses
it died yeah people die all the time
you've heard of that I got a homie who's
tried to stuff a half a half ounce of
crack in his ass and he died in the
police station it's a serious serious
amount of crap to try to fend your butt
I'm just saying the amount of lube
needed for that to transpire that's two
percent gay for sure it probably doesn't
matter how many layers of bag are in
between that you know because it's your
body's acidic you got acids in you yeah
it should be like you should at least
it's like when you uh you gotta put it
in a corner and like wrap it into
another corner right it's like if you
vacuum seal a pack and put it in the
mail you should at least do it three
times allegedly I mean you know once you
start once that machine gets the buzzing
you know you might just do it you just
got to make sure you get you're good
with the Poke test you know I don't I
wouldn't know anything about that but
I've heard I don't know yeah